guys doing make some knowledge if you
like
hp
it's good to be here
the sponsor of mighty angle that's a
little bit more comfortable standing
straight
the featherweight
the woman's one-liner division
here she is queen colin
not much how's the your day been it's
pretty good
i don't wonder
hans asked me about my name being quinn
collins in this similarity to colin
quinn and asked me if i did that on
purpose
but it's her actual name
it's not a pseudonym like i thought it
was you know we are in the show business
after all it's true that's true could
have been playing it way smarter than i
am yeah but it's a complete accident
yeah i just got it for my birthday i
don't know anything other than that a
birthday name wow
it is her birthday here so give it up
for her it's not my
i am it's it's not herbert my birthday's
actually may 31st gemini
um but uh that's quite who here knows
who colin quinn is
no one knows comedy it's really my time
to shine now
she also you know has a very uh active
instagram account you can follow her
no it's uh it's great um
are you ready to watch people date
that's going out live on youtube
so just
sprung that on you before you go on a
date on stage so don't say anything too
crazy
uh you guys ready for this dash to go
get going
that guy is he has honey
um
what was your name again i'm so sorry
cody
he's one of the few men that is going to
go on a date today
if you have a if you have a uh desire to
go on a date two days a day
uh amy
up the grove
ooh amy there she is her friend
outing her right away
she has to come up
go on a date with none other than cody
50 50 chance wow so now come here
give it up for
cody and amy up the grove
let's go
i already have high hopes
it's going into every day and it never
works out well for me but
maybe for other people there's always
reason to be hopeful
um we're gonna do a minute of dating and
then we're gonna interview them after
the one minute so here we go
hi how are you i'm doing well how are
you good where are you from uh i'm from
here from austin round rock if you want
to get real specific about it unicorn i
guess
i just you guys do i mean i feel rare
but not exotic fair enough
fair enough what do you do for work uh
for work uh i am a support tech for a
video game company uh people write in
with problems and i write in with
answers and say you deal with idiots
yeah
lots of that
i got that yeah did that for a long time
yes and in my spare time my beekeeper i
just brought a bunch of honey here today
to chop up i think it's going to go in
the cocktail so i love that yeah there's
i drink honey and my tea every day
it's really
it's a really fun hobby i enjoy it how
can you get stuck uh not today
thankfully but i usually get stuck at
least once a month it's kind of
unavoidable it's just sort of a hazard
um what do you like to do for your
hobbies and stuff i swim constantly have
a pool in my backyard i have a pup that
keeps me crazy busy her nickname one
time give it up for amy up the grove and
cody
are y'all in love
is your last name up to grove
wow very official that was a flawless
date not a mistake was made
to say that was like very smooth
yeah that was well this is like an
episode of girls or something
her toenails and her fingernails match
though so i don't think a guy in a
bandanna has a great shot but i think it
was still oh [ __ ]
he does have that
oh
i mean how's that going for him that's
true
like curly hair always a plus i'm pretty
deep
he also looks like jackie from
scooby-doo so that's like nostalgic so
it looks like uh yeah
he looks like johnny depp from pirates
of the caribbean if he's [ __ ]
we're just roasting cody up here forget
how well that date went i'm sorry i
called you [ __ ]
and you are definitely amber heard uh oh
my god
wow uh oh okay a lot of johnny depp fans
in the audience is bad with that joe
cons
well yeah i mean i guess uh
what what's your dating history like
what who have you dated recently
recently
i mean i've been single for three years
and i'm a picky so
what would you say if you had to be
picky is wrong with cody
i'm sorry cody um i i have a feeling
he's significantly younger than me
what you're inexperienced he's got a
face that was probably a virgin like 21
or he's 35 and there's not going to be
an in between
none
i'm horrible at judging h so that's hard
for me to pinpoint he looks like if
david dobrik took coyote
very literary reference i don't know not
a david dobrik no
oh nice the girls get it cody it's you
and i we're dumb as [ __ ]
you look like you have a house at zulker
park i wish
that would be a million dollar house
how old are you cody i'm 28 years old i
was so right about that
wow you're older than 28.
i thought you were 12
is that a good guess that's what you're
supposed to do with women
well he would be the pedophile which we
already knew that
like well not technically i guess could
you be a pedophile but like you wouldn't
be i'd be a so you're older than cody
significantly older than cody is there
anything you want to teach him right now
maybe about the date you just went on
you know for a 28 year old cody you are
totally holding your own thank you
totally
that's the goal i'm here for it thank
you for sure or it's you
absolutely so cody what's your dating
life like who have you been dating you
throw up on any chicks recently not
recently thank goodness cody
accidentally threw up during sex once
this is something we found out about it
yeah it's cody you wanna hear the most
embarrassing [ __ ] i heard about anyone
his favorite color is green
men are so nice i'll forgive any mistake
um
i haven't blown cody's chances yet
you're still in this cody
it's just one of those things you gotta
take it slow and steady can't rush into
things panic happens you can't rush into
dating anyone you rushed into dating
recently no
taking it slow and steady oh
what do you what do you think about uh
the people cody's dated do you think
they're like
personal experience yeah or who do i
think he dates yeah i was listening i
don't know her um
it's about to be amy up the grove
hopefully right
i'm fine with that
thank you
they're both down for it anyways down
for that video you think
go on a casual day talk me they're
getting married
this is a millennial thought
i kind of just wanted to talk to her for
a while
millennials [ __ ] this is autism on the
spectrum for sure
uh what do you
what do you think about uh the people
cody's dated
i think that they uh look like just a
different variation of himself every
time think you're blonde definitely
definitely blonde they share that breaks
hard
he looks like a hippie but he loves a
republican
he loves a girl that's like i'm just
really socially liberal but fiscally my
dad pays all my bills
red hats he does make his own money he
works in i.t
amy what do you do for work
my background's in emergency medicine
now i run a chiropractic practice so you
are
a hero during the pandemic
i was out of the er so i will not claim
that but i was frontline worker that
continued to see patients every single
day i respect you and honor you and uh
you're doing a lot more for our society
than uh
what's the craziest thing that you've
seen in an emergency situation
i've been handed limbs
i've um
what limb what's your favorite my
favorite
the guy that put his foot put his foot
in a boot on my triage desk
and i was hella pissed that's a limb i
was like really one
his actual foot
but yeah did we put it back on oh you
can do that now
talk about putting your best foot
forward
that that was that's i've been handed
plenty of fingers toes plenty of fingers
what is going on out there why are
people losing their fingers
so i'm from the midwest
okay you get you can you don't need to
say anymore
those midwest idiots they're basically
cattle
amen that's why i got out
that's awesome combine i actually have
no idea where missouri is like gun to my
head if you showed me a map of america
i'm done
no idea somewhere right smack dab in the
middle
i've got like a back dab i'll be
honest cody have you ever uh been in an
emergency situation
yes there was a shooting at the jewelry
store next to my first job in a strip
mall oh [ __ ] yes
then what did you do to help the
situation i called 9-1-1 locked the door
and
hid i was the only one there at the time
what were you working at yeah okay amy's
on board
for that i went to high school with one
of the people that was being shot at
apparently and one of the robbers oh
found that out
seven degrees somebody scored the robber
or the victim the robber
he was also a victim of being shot i
guess
that's how the police found him
points he's i wouldn't say he was a
friend he's just a guy i graduated cody
is such a liberal he even thinks
criminals are victims
i
it's hard to not be shot and like say
ouch like i'd consider yourself a
gunshot it you make honey cody is that
what no the bees make honey but i
harvest it can i ask you a question sure
do you think that bees have lips
no have you ever seen one under a
microscope i mean no you should okay
that's all right
fun facts with quinn collin
she knows animal facts i do is it true
that uh in the er like during a full
moon it's crazier it is bat [ __ ] crazy
calling
is it really [ __ ] crazy during the full
moon
on a full moon
luckily
cody never works anyway at all
cody actually has a job in i.t so good
for him so let's do a little role
playing let's say uh a young patient
named cody comes in
and uh
you he's a fancy little lad you know
you're trying to get some dating uh
going on and cody you just get the pawn
just that's right okay yeah
well you know some say
medicine
uh and then cody you just got stung all
over you're just a hapless little lad
trying to get his dick wet with the
nurse
and go
action
yeah uh help nurse i need up an effort
oh you definitely need an epipen all
right going right in your thigh
i mean you're gonna have to drop your
pants for that so i'm not that much i'm
too swollen i can't get the pants off
you're gonna have to cut them off
you're gonna have to cut them off me
i can do i can handle that i don't know
what would happen
i assume you've got some pants off
the table all swollen
the last thing i'm thinking about is sex
but you will end up naked in a room
alone i don't think me
be venom is an aphrodisiac
no some people might be into that but
not me
the honey
but
in it in a different format
i think the best foreign has this kind
of dialogue at the beginning every time
if the dialogue and foreign isn't
comfortably hard to watch you know it's
gonna be a good rest of the video three
times
the [ __ ] is gonna be good
they gotta get it all out through the
genitals give it up for amy and uh cody
they went on a date
i think they're gonna [ __ ]
i hope so
they're wearing similar pants
if you want to sign up please go ahead
and sign up we need more people we only
got one more couple coming up uh or we
could have sam come up or a cameraman
very handsome man if anyone wants to go
on a date with
an alabama redneck that's always
available
but we got an austin coming up
i don't know if she put her city name
down or her actual last name is austin
and we got mike linehan
local comedian
that first day
great it's gone even better than every
day that you're not just like
[ __ ] a dancer yeah not good
very good
give it up for
mike linehan and
jen austin
and date
so whoop so what brings you here amy
optigrove
well thank you amy um
nice
are you are you local are you from here
around
um what's your address
no i'm just kidding so what are you into
what do you so you're here so you must
like be
kind of adventurous this takes a lot of
guts
love having fun my goal in life is to
have all the fun try all the experiences
go all the places meet all the people
so like yesterday i went wake surfing
for the first time
day before that i went to
austin's waterloo adventures and i did
that ops floating obstacle course thing
before that aquatic adventure then new
mexico riding horses oh [ __ ] a little
bit of bareback a little bit of fixing
fences a little bit of
oh
getting a little excited on this date
this man is wearing a polo ball cap and
a tommy hill figure shirt he's living in
a time where sugar ray was still number
one on the internet
it's definitely a douche bag
um what a uh have you ever ridden i've
been for ridden a horse um
you know i i guided a horse a little bit
you've guided a horse
yeah through um
hard times no
no i i i
i visited a camp in uh right outside of
jerusalem where
where young men go that are at youth
risk and they go and they hang out with
horses and they bond
and exist and i volunteered my time
there
jen austin how does that story make you
feel about dating mike linehan
pretty creepy i yeah that's a bad story
but i grew up here he's a volunteer in
israel
yeah do you uh you ride horses can you
could you teach him how to ride horses
yes
okay
how do you think he would do in that
situation you think maybe he would uh
[ __ ] it up or something oh horses know
what to do he'll be fine yeah i'm a cool
guy
horses pick up on on that energy you
know it's all it's a big energy game
with the horses you know
not the wings
knock it in there if i was a horse and
you walked up to me i'd be like uh oh
he's gonna stick a carrot up my ass or
something look at that he looks like a
prep bro you know you could only dream
hans but uh
well yeah we're here dating on a live
podcast
well he's still trying to
keep it sexy
uh
it's been a stable date so far
great joke
great horse jokes got a good foot one
earlier too
uh jen austin
what do you think about the uh whole
horse situation why do you like bareback
so much
with horses i mean with horse you
wouldn't want to bear back a human
i i really don't have a good answer i
have a legit answer it's not going to be
funny so you do the saddle you do the
english saddle and then the uh
the western side oh we are in texas
the corn yeah you gotta have the horn
you can't just smash your balls into
nothing
uh what what is uh what is it you like
about the different saddles and
what can you teach mike linehan about
horses
so he was on track horses pick up on
personalities and they see into your
soul so it's a great time to just check
out of the real world and just check in
to your large livestock that can kill
you yeah as i say everything you've said
about horses so far has made me more
scared
they can see inside your soul jesus
christ horses are so large dude i'm
scared shitless of horses
maya i used to babysit a girl that was
an equestrian and it would be like a
bunch of girls that are like this tall
just running around these giant
creatures and i want to go in because
like every time it would be like a bunch
of them like walking towards you scared
the [ __ ] out of me so they probably
don't like me because they picked up on
that energy you just have to blow in
their nose i won't do that but
jen you're talking about bareback and
blowing
we're only getting mike hard over here
so what's your favorite uh horse that
you have
opie
any similarities between ob and mike
linehan
dope
sometimes you know it's hard to avoid
there you go
mike what's uh what's something you
could offer uh a jen over here in terms
of your animal knowledge he seems to be
very into animals well he i actually did
grow up across the street from uh this
place called the animal rescue league if
he lives close to a thing with animals
in it but uh
please don't look this place up and go
murder my family but um yeah i lived
across the street from like a place that
like uh would there was a dog shout
their catch out their horse would you do
anything there or did you just watch
from across the street i sometimes would
go feed the horses apples and [ __ ] and
then my dog would run off are you
allowed was this illegal feeding or did
they frown upon it
you have to sneak an apple up there
one that heard something about murdering
his family like did anyone else here
murder his family and then they'll
murder mike smith
what did you say well i don't want to
just like describe where my parents live
you just did live on youtube you can
look it up later [ __ ] if you really want
to
i also grew up near an animal rescue i
thought that was something you're really
dodged yeah
i also want to murder my family
wow what uh what kind of animal rescue
big cat rescue
next to joe exotic
tiger king no
no way did you really
she's from florida everyone run away
so you're a floridian
oh so almost as bad as finding out
mike's a jew
jesus is christ
hilarious all right
um but how did you how did you know
carol baskin did you uh talk to her at
all
on the trail on a bike do you think she
killed her husband
would you kill mike linehan
you do or you don't you do you think she
did she did oh yeah yeah was that the
same trail joe exotic was hiding on
and like
that's his fields oh that was his
property
he didn't go hide remember there was a
hitman i don't remember it kind of i
guess like
from florida you got to watch tiger king
at least seven times with her yeah where
are you from oh
i can find your family and i'm just
kidding
i'm from uh some a mean place where
you're either a cop or a criminal um
america i'm saying they're the same
thing
i'm just glad they made it out alive i'm
from uh the hard streets of boston
massachusetts well nobody's made it out
of there alive before you're one of the
few yeah so is there any boston
aphorisms that you could uh say right
now like you know show me them apples
oh [ __ ] uh last time i came on here i
pulled out some
some shadow [ __ ] um why did some shadow
[ __ ]
is that a full moon tonight are you
about to meet amy updrove in the er
yeah shout out to amy up the grove for
setting this up but um no i i really
have nothing big to pull out today i i'm
sorry
nothing you can say in your boston
answer
like someone's not going to get
barebacked
no blown up
is is there a ranch around here you want
to
make this no matching jacket
is there a ranch in texas
it's like asking if there's a douchebag
in boston massachusetts
now boston great studio colleges well
there will be in a couple weeks are you
touring there whoa call me a douchebag
the nerdiest nerd i mean if you're gonna
go with an insult try autistic keep it
relevant
uh jen what's uh what's your dating
history like have you dated a lot of
mike linehans
yes
wow
what
what what do you think is characteristic
of mike linehan's like what what did
they have in common
who have you dated or what were they
what's your type
anyways ben is falling apart at the seam
she's uh
looking into our souls like a horse
she doesn't want to answer those
questions mike who have you dated
um
i i got a i got a track record of okay
great story of
no never shot heroin i i've been
addicted to other drugs but that's
besides
we couldn't tell at all
i've dated some wild chicks i've dated
some wool chicks
yeah any honestly i'm down for whatever
the longest relationship i've had was
like two years and like i've only had
like a few long relationships like that
and then his dad left him
yeah
it's been tough
worse breakup story uh
i was like i told this last time i came
on here but i was like desperately in
love with a chick in high school like my
like high school like like girlfriend
and also it was probably just because
like this chick had sex with me when i
was 14.
so like i was roped in you know it was
like literally yeah bareback yeah barry
was she was very bare
and
wow unprotected sex at 14. yeah you
thought that south had bad sex education
and so like when a woman has a power
over a young boy like that
and is she a woman or just a girl like
you my age okay like i call people well
she's a woman now and i don't want
people to like picture like two kids
having sex um
that's what it was but here
can i keep going uh yeah please go on
with this story about children [ __ ]
all right
thank you
solid so
she has power over you she had me you
know it's it's one of those tanks
you've got a boner right now it's really
uncomfortable
it's one of those things
where a dude
it can easily just be manipulated into
like doing anything a rare thing that
never happens it happens a lot let's be
honest but um
especially in boston
all right what that makes no sense but
so
let's catch all the thicker things here
so she she um comes over my house one
day and she she [ __ ] me but she didn't
just like [ __ ] me she did like that uh
[ __ ] from uh what's that movie called
bareback cousins volume three
hit the nail on the head
and no she was [ __ ] me like that last
scene of
i had a head injury recently i'm really
losing no energy
you did say you grew up in boston so i
think that covers intensity trying to
find a lost dog i'm like what is it
[ __ ] you like a movie and then she
left you and then she left me yeah and
um it [ __ ] up your head and if [ __ ]
up with [ __ ] with me i was desperate
for [ __ ] i was like a crackhead but for
[ __ ] you know i was like 17 or no i was
like 16.
so like you get accustomed to shooting
up this
vagina you know shooting up this vagina
and god damn
and you're just feening and scratching
and i got ratcheting there's a [ __ ]
no no no oh it's an itch you gotta
scratch you gotta get vagina it's a drug
addiction so you're a horny
fourteen-year-old boy well how did you
oh i pressed your frustrations
i would not want to fill the show with
you
i mean i know you'd want to fill up some
[ __ ] with your
boston juice but what happened to the
story all right so boston cream pie you
missed the perfect opportunity
so
so we're broken up some time goes on i'm
kicking around you know doing my thing
maybe picking up a bag on the street
a box on the street you know and um he's
talking boston this is what i wanted the
whole time and she she texts me one
night out of the blue she's like hey
what are you doing and i'm just [ __ ]
a fein you know i'm addicted so i i
immediately go there
we were 17 at the time yeah and um
we were at a party
uh one thing turned to another
dark stuff but we ended up drinking
underage oh
and you're drinking
that's illegal at that age
it was dark man
is there an end to this story
yeah we're gonna get there we [ __ ] and
she gave me chlamydia
yeah
not the scd that can be cured by a pill
yeah no it was a good time the easiest
sdd to cure that's the one you want it's
almost like not having an std
yeah no it was fine um your piss burns
for like two mornings until you figure
it out but uh let's just remind everyone
that mike is still on a date right now
with the beautiful jen
so far he said picking up boxes and bags
you know that my piss burns you don't
have to
a man that looks like that talking about
himself the entire date no one would
have guessed no one would have predicted
that jen do you uh have any advice for
him on a storytelling maybe
get to the punch line don't i'm sorry
erase it from your memories
choose another breakup there were a
couple
that wasn't interesting
let's knock it off in the crowd all
right he's getting heckled by the peanut
gallery
no one's getting off in the crowd when
you're talking don't worry
they're not helping you fulfill your
addiction
no no and this is the new parade of
austin residents
the addiction actually i've been on now
he's into dudes no
john what did
he found he was jerking oh i found my
heart is what it is
oh
now he worships the lord jesus christ
every sunday no still jewish
but no
yeah well i i found my heart and i grew
up you know and uh jew finds a heart
what a relief yeah so jen
how long have you been in texas for
in texas four plus three seven years wow
so three years during the pandemic
three years that's been three it's not
been three years it's been two years
since
it's going on year three well i'm
counting for the chinese calendar
we started a bit earlier than you guys
it's been around no i was in san antonio
for four and then austin for three oh
you're a texan uh for seven years san
antonio uh austin's boston if you will
uh what did you like to do
[ __ ] it up dude what you love awesome
that much that's so weird oh my god
what did you like to do in san antonio
where would you take mike linehan if you
happen to be in san antonio together wow
he's dying for it to be about him right
now so would you like to sign up we need
more
dates up on stage we'd love to have you
you know you seem a little chatty
tonight so sign up sign up sign put down
the booze and pick up a pen lady oh my
god don't be mean to her this is how
they talk to women in boston
literally wait you could go on a date
with a great mike linehan
uh-oh sorry about that mike kind of hurt
but no actually we're having fun
i made all of you guys
telling us what we're feeling
you know you should tell her where she
would take you in san antonio
yeah um
where would she take you if she took you
to where she's my ideal day
september 11th
all right no no i'm just sh i just got
that idea from her that's a bad joke but
no i i honestly
we got that idea from like i think
that's mean girls right i don't know
that's miss congeniality oh my gosh
uh yeah it's a bad dream basic [ __ ] no
my ideal date is honestly anything would
just sometimes you click with people and
you can realize that in the first like
30 to 40 minutes of being with them
40 minutes and maybe i i don't know um
i think you would take her
answer these questions
you want to go paintballing that would
be [ __ ] that would actually be bad
ass
you guys want to come to make this a
little less awkward
no mike you're going on a date you don't
bring other people on dates you try to
[ __ ] the person you're with true
i feel like mike would take his day to
his drug dealer's house and they would
sit on a couch
and watch planet earth
anyways jen
where what is the craziest place
someone's taking you on a date
that's what you should ask me earlier
what do i usually do on dates but i go
on adventures all the time can you tell
in 30 to 40 minutes if you click florida
so i say she goes on adventures
her dates are always great
i know a thing or two about people from
florida if anyone over 45 tries to be
your friend they're trying to lick you
and they have a
spouse
trying to lick you
they're swingers
you uh you ever get licked in uh in
florida all right
no what's the
best date you've been on in florida
i didn't actually date in florida
um so rare
fluoridate flurries either it makes you
feel any better
think about it i so you're telling me
you never got swamp ass no
well welcome to austin
solid
no i
yeah i'm just striking out left and
right up here i'm dying up here let's be
honest keep talking
trying to take myself out of this hole
but um
paintballing sounds fun actually i was
thinking about it
he's taking it back to paintball
have you ever been have you ever
such a hard time trying to ask a woman
about herself right now you can he's
like sweating
no um
i'm just pretty high
and and there's no way and there's um
honestly there is a weird like feeling
of being on stage where like you have to
also make it funny and it's called
performing you're a comedian yeah and so
jen uh how did you learn how to
paintball
i got a gun
she got a gun
the hopper
yeah and then you pull the trigger and
they come out what's your strategy nice
hold the trigger a lot oh nice
like uh
how would you respond to getting shot
i i've been shot multiple times i i grew
up around weaponry well airsoft guns
paintball gun that's what he calls a
weaponry in boston you're in texas now
[ __ ] those are called toys yeah yeah i
i'll call it [ __ ] weaponry yeah i had a
lot of toys when i was a kid i guess but
um yeah i'm pretty sure you've been
telling me about yourself a lot no me my
friends we would all go and uh play at
uh
thoughts and paintball
yeah we were doing
younger
it was a song
it actually was
and then he goes forward as if he's
going to go take over the other team and
i just shoot him in the back she's a
little friendly fire really hurt over
here oh
i like her
uh that sounds fun
no yeah because his back is turning
because he trusts you
exactly
make it weird
uh jen so what do you think about mike
do you think he's too young for you
probably
how old is this man
i'm uh 23. no you're not
yeah
yeah that's probably exactly what i
would have guessed yeah well just proves
the blink 182 song right am i right
those two you're right
nobody gets me
all right
this is going to turn into adam's song
real quick
uh mike you're a great man you're you're
handsome you're young you have a
little [ __ ] apparently but
they don't have to know about that you
you're you're out there you're slinging
it what's what's the craziest thing
you've done so far in austin oh [ __ ] um
uh i really haven't done that many that
much crazy [ __ ] i've had a few it's hard
for him to get to it
so much time
i gotta take a bird scooter
i've had a few jobs um
i i've lost a few jobs he's been here
two weeks he's had seven jobs already
i i can't i yeah i've i've struggled i i
just moved a new apartment i live on
sixth street that's pretty interesting
um i fell off a lime scooter i know i
bashed my brain pretty hard have you
gone skydiving let's do it i mean i i i
that's one thing i'm i hate flying it's
just like being off the ground like i'm
naturally like
i'm next
yeah
i'm gonna stand up from boston
i can get off the ground with this
dating thing
i will literally skydive with you to get
some [ __ ] this is some
serious dedication
no well there's just many things i want
to do in my life and uh i'm so focused
on comedy and in love with it like if i
don't perform i can't like listen to
music like if i haven't performed in
like a day or two
no but this is like like just part of
like no way like the only thing i like
really care about so like when i have
friends that are outside of comedy like
that'll just like push me to do things
that are
normal things because i
on my own i would never like what's your
favorite joke
um can you tell jen a joke that would
make her interested in comedy
you know
i i really it can be a street joke it
could be someone else's joke just
anything oh i can i can reference a hans
kim joke let's hear it for your jokes
though
do you want to hear mike you what can i
tell a joke the crowd like to hear mike
lenahan original jokes you guys want to
hear one of my jokes all right
stand up for this oh [ __ ] it's called
stand up not sit down i'm a stand-up
comedian i'm a stand-up comedian uh i'm
going through it guys it's tough being
young
white handsome with flawless hair in
texas
for one every tap on the shoulder has
been a gender reveal
michael michelle
handsome
sexy
bruce
caitlyn
that was like poetry give it up for mike
linehan
regaling us with some jokes
i would never hit on a girl with
shoulders like yours
got a thing for linebackers
you're gonna try again without the fanny
pack
so i might oh well i thought my mic was
off yeah the fanny pack it it's a real
douchebag look but
it's
it's tough out here uh i come from a
place in many pockets
what does that mean
he's like a lord of the rings characters
from cargo pants
can i get from the 90s can i get to the
[ __ ] dick of it we wish
we've been waiting for that for 26
minutes
what are you gonna say
i swear i just completely forgot what i
was gonna
oh
there's a doctor amy we need your help
up here uh no
wait whoa it's a cat scan
pocket banned from a plate
man in many pockets
of many pockets so
where i come from
the weather
it's colder
so you're going to wear a jacket you're
going to wear pants
get pockets so you could have just said
that instead of saying i'm from a land
of many pockets
you skipped a step there
i think it's funny land of many pockets
and now you're here with the fanny pack
on because you miss your pockets i need
a couple more pockets yeah
i feel like your brain is a land of many
pockets
[ __ ] like
you know he's got a brain injury but he
has a great joke about how he looks like
a woman
uh i have i have a curse let's be honest
i
i have a curse with this gift of comedy
and i might waxing poetically during his
date and
i'm a real deep guy
well i would
vincent deep close enough
and
okay i think he's done i i think he just
finished that i'm having trouble getting
through but i'd love to get to know you
that's all i'm trying to say
he's asked her wow great question about
herself i gotta go full circle finally
acknowledges his date
that was wonderful mike i think first
name quickly what's her first name
quickly five four three name easiest one
amy
no
all right last name easy easy this is a
gimme where are you right now guinea
it's a yeah it's a give me and it gives
you the answer where are you right now
it's italian mike is broken out right
now
oh our name is jen what's her last name
oh jen austin oh
give it up for mike he did something
right for once
i'm sorry jeff don't uh don't look for
the handshake
it's okay
that's an interesting uh scenario that
just happened mike you uh you're feeling
good you're feeling happy about yourself
but i'm a 50 50 right now be honest with
you hans okay well for a pop tonight
that's normal
i would love to see this boston florida
union happen that sounds loud yeah
that sounds like
alcoholism you know yeah you drink
i'm not answering that she pleased the
fit
yeah i don't i i don't drink sometimes i
will though like i'm easy to get tempted
with a good time
you did yeah
mike is uh willing to go skydiving with
a chick he doesn't know her name but uh
well see here's the thing honest
i can't wait
i gotta think of it as i go when i do
here's a little inside baseball when i
do something like that i gotta like
think of it on the fly so it starts with
a sentence and like
give it up for mike linehan and jen
austin thank you
they went on a date johnny more like
that for him do not
do not do anything with that fifth on
like every question asked about her i'm
gonna start doing that on dates i go on
dates and they're like what's your
favorite color
and i'm like oh well when i was five uh
just tell them a whole bunch of [ __ ]
they don't wanna hear well this says a
lot about you as a person yeah i do all
the time i say a lot about me we're
gonna get sam kiper up here sam
and coming up with candace
let's sign up please go ahead and sign
up we've got a lot of eligible
bachelor's we're going to get cody to
come up again or even mike linehan if
that's more speed
but give it up for candace and samuel
kuiper
i'm good
where are you from
knoxville
tennessee yeah
okay i was worried i thought i was gonna
get that wrong uh i'm not uh good at
geography um yeah to be honest yeah
what do you like how long you've been
here uh like
six months do you like it so far that's
great it's kind of weird there's no
mountains
yeah that's true we got like
nature but yeah not too many mountains i
guess
there's a lot of water yeah have you
been paddle boarding or
uh yeah i almost threw point off the
paddleboard were you guys on the same
paddleboard
no you were yeah who was in my dreams
uh did you guys have a
cooler beer were you guys like on
mushrooms you guys just out there no but
i did drop an entire joint in the water
you dropped an entire joint
watch me air it out did it work
how did it
smoke
it didn't i have to say yeah and time
give it up for sam kuiper and candace
i love
napoleon dynamite
is there a scene in napoleon dynamite
where he drops a joint yeah from the
beginning
what a cool guy i don't know how cool he
was
so
sam you're from alabama you said that
you don't know much about geography uh
i think that's given yeah with your
haircut
uh
i don't know the same haircut
you got the same haircut as a woman does
anyone ever confuse you with a woman
when your back is turned
no
um
no no
michael anahan has that over here yeah
the shoulders too but i think
we're both too he's a chunky little
big man i think you're in the wrong bar
if you're getting mike wherever you're
at you're getting ahead of something
yeah it's a lot of lesbian bars michael
inahan yeah yeah
candace what's your uh what's your
thoughts on sam kuiper the alabama that
doesn't know much geography
it's okay i don't know about sharp
either um
i don't know what a what a handsome
young man
oh let's go
he looks like a little boy
it's very she's like
middle school math teacher
i think my worst subject shocking you
know yeah the guy from alabama i don't
have a math
you look like a bud tender
okay
yeah yeah you look like you tend butts
that's an insult in alabama
uh candace uh you pushed quinn our
lovely guest tonight you push her off a
paddleboard
an attempt
[Music]
how did this happen did you were you
like you mad at dancing to bruno mars
we were trying to you know
sit there and hang out and the wind was
not having it and then
when pushed your arm into quincy and
we're sitting there trying to fear the
paddle boards and we had like just the
one thing instead of the right ones
you're supposed to use like the canoe
things so we're sitting there like
desperately trying to get back and we're
just going in circles
like around and around like people are
we're definitely watching us and we're
like getting like noticeably angry about
it just like go on and shoved her
roommate off of the paddleboard
making us look bad as a unit
we were both doing it like it was like
so was one person paddling too hard and
the other person wasn't paddling enough
no we both just didn't know what we were
doing we were both going in circles
that's when you need uh semen over there
like mike linehan
he's on he's on the boston shores just
paddling his life right
uh but that's a that's unfortunate did
they just give out paddle boards without
any licenses like guns nowadays they're
just giving out paddles you just give me
your id which is more than you even have
to do
the only way to stop a bad guy with the
paddleboard is a good guy with your
paddleboard okay paddleboards don't kill
people
people kill paddleboards
what is uh what is the lesson you
learned during this paddle board
excursion
um i learned don't [ __ ] with quinn
yeah she backhanded you
i keep my pants fantastic like fall and
like i will not stand on the paddleboard
there's no need for that
okay
okay you like paddle boarding sam i've
been a few times it's fun i do think uh
i'm a fan yeah do you ever go on a date
paddle boarding i haven't been on a date
paddle boarding just with the neither is
candace
yeah we have to uh get two though i
won't share i will say
i will show you
you don't want to uh do a titanic
situation
what uh what body of water which best
describes you ladybird lake or lake
austin
like austin why
why is it disgusting
uh got more bodies than anything you can
count
i actually don't know i know nothing
about like austin
it could be very nice what do you have
to say about your roommates dating
because i mean you live together you you
guys knock elbows you notice any trends
knock elbows
all right yeah i mean i want she should
date i mean i think it's austin it's
such a cool place to be single yeah
which is why
they should they should go on a paddle
board date because i know she likes them
but
she's not great at like the paddling so
he can show her his stroke game since
he's so much oh
i think for stroking you want mike
linehan he seems more like a broker
but sam gets laid
you got two buttons on it's pretty much
unbuttoned right now it's hot man i was
at latchkey you guys ever heard alaska
another hour in a promo
oh my gosh i have no affiliation that's
just a dope spot good energy good music
so true it's hot though it's hot [ __ ]
and i'm just comfy don't hate them look
you just
okay what fits if everyone's listening
to you
you just got all sudden so defensive
about it sam what's your go-to move on a
date
oh i don't know man uh humor i guess try
to make a lap okay make candace laugh
crush in it uh yeah it's not vance
bombing yeah i feel like that's um yeah
i don't know man this is this is gonna
end up poorly
she laughed
she laughed
there was a silent laugh i got it i got
a posture
okay can you make sam laugh
no
we're not going to work i don't think
i'm still waiting on this one
no oh i can't do it look
you both look like different variations
of someone who has an extremely
republican father like
one's leaning into it one's rebelling
against it
candace are you vaccinated
yeah
she's vaccinated and you are definitely
not
did you get it up accident waxed baby
i'm ready get it up the butt you pack it
uh but yeah you're you're vaccinated
you're both vaccinated so uh
what do you do for words
oh yeah that's fun uh
did you have that is that why you moved
austin okay hell yeah
so you're
still liking it six months in
uh yeah i just got off of a tour last
week so i haven't really been here that
much i've been here like a month in
total what kind of that's fun what kind
of tour uh we just finished uh season 14
of american ninja warrior oh [ __ ] whoa
she works at american ninja warrior give
it up for her it's supporting asian tv
[ __ ] yeah
the hands doesn't change
you need all the help you can get your
people right is it thanks
new people whenever an alabama says you
people
yeah you're people i said but
uh so candace what do you think about
sam's chances you think you'd be able to
get up that wall or
something i feel like i feel like this
war falls pretty pretty good for him
rupaul
oh what did you say warped wall
what's the warp wall i'm having a stroke
yeah
where are we rock climbing now what are
we doing what's the american ninja
warrior the one oh oh i didn't know it
existed
some men hear a woman talk about herself
and they're like
it's cool i don't know typical center
date they like
monkey they got monkey bars besides
something like that whoa sam you came on
i basically wrote a show so
he's basically like on the on the team
so what do you do on the set you uh are
you a camera person
a production assistant and a facilities
manager so i make sure that shit's
running like a ship
nice
so if you were to uh production manage a
date with sam kuiper where would you go
and uh
how many guns would you shoot
um i feel like 14 is a good amount of
guns that's like a
happy medium number
yeah and that's it we're just going to
take 14 guns into the woods that's the
whole day
sam how does that make you feel 14 guns
are you in control of all 14 guns i
don't know depends on how how fast you
are
uh duel yeah
i just uh what are we doing with 14 guns
that's uh that's for god to decide
that's what you do with guns you just
take them out and see what happens yeah
it's like gun god america that that's
that sounds republican i know sounds
good god republican solid star in the
woods
so uh you know it's a touchy subject
maybe we could uh get off it uh what do
you think about abortions
nice
i love them exactly she loves them she
has a bandana on of course she loves
abortion
sam have you been responsible for any
abortion yeah actually like
wow yeah actually
that's like a true story like 10 months
ago yeah and uh i'd be a dad right now
yeah that's how abortions work yeah
do you guys know how abortion works
because i
that also we're gonna have a kid and
then we did it i'd be a month into
fatherhood i would probably would
i wanted to go here
ten months ago i'm saying right now i'd
be like a month into fatherhood right so
like nine months man
i said ten months ago
he knocked the chicken baby would be
born right now if i didn't ten months
ago abortion was still legal
yeah and you you got one right away are
we just backs like up here now
it's not illegal yet it's about to be
crazy they'll do it
yeah do anyone want abortion
all abortions must go
it was her choice though actually which
i was relieved but uh nation she said it
and i paid for it so i mean i feel like
nice i did my part
what a feminist yeah
so uh you know sam has gotten an
abortion before is that like a big deal
do you think that he's like a he's like
a republican that takes all the benefits
of free weed and abortion but he's
paying
yeah
why even wrap it up anymore just [ __ ]
shoot it in there and
pop it out
what's the best day or no i don't care
about that what's the worst day you've
ever been on
uh i had
there's a girl here in austin i went on
a date with it she told me that uh
specifically date one she told me
she was already like asking if i wanted
to get married and then she's nice
saying am i comfortable with being a
stay-at-home dad
and i was like it was way too much it
was it rocks um
yeah but like yeah i'd rather work she
said that yeah she well i like
creatively i'd rather do something i
asked i was like okay so like you're it
sounds like you're rich and she was like
yeah my family owns like an oil whatever
i was like okay so my family owns oil do
i get help like can we get a nanny and
she was like no that's why you'd stay
home and i was like is this on a first
date first date just recruiting first
date i was like no so they do it in
texas yeah just recruit them yeah you
try to
so smart though she's knocking out all
the hard questions ready
that's wild yeah first date in the last
day too you could have been bill clinton
nice
yeah no she said i couldn't have any
help she was like i was like we can get
like a maid she's like no and i was like
[ __ ] why am i still why can't i work
no i'm not
i
would be sober i just know me like i'll
probably i'll probably cheat i got you
know what i mean like you're a male
feminist is what you are you're like i
don't wrong in the kitchen i'm not gonna
have a maid i'm gonna cheat if i don't
have it
can't i'm just saying like then i gotta
raise the kid and clean at the same time
raise it and clean it new every day i
need to help is all i'm saying like why
can't she help me she was like no i'm
not going to help and i was like so it's
all on me
i can't do it i need help
it's just i don't need to do anything
you want to have a personality and
thoughts
no get back in the kitchen
that's where men belong is making me a
sandwich i'm not allowed to wear a watch
anymore because there's one on the stove
you know
candace what's the worst date you've
ever been on all of them i agree but
candace hates dating
nice one time i came back from the
bathroom the guy was just on tender oh
man oh
[ __ ] good first date
oh i feel like i've done that
yeah when you're dating you're in the
mood for dating you're like oh that's
awesome
you know what sounds good fun in the
next one yeah i love this so much i want
to do this
so uh you you're a tinder user
have you ever done any of the other apps
um
you don't want any of the other that's
like a drug uh i'm with play on hand
hinge i love that there's like a true
market competition for dating app it's
not like uber i do think there's some
that are better than the rest i think i
just think hinge is like the most
organized one except i don't i like how
on tinder it's like
someone liked you it's 3 30 a.m and it's
like still night you know names on hinge
it's like quinn liked you at 4 25. she's
blackout drunk she's on hinge right now
and i don't like that it calls you out
specifically like that i like the anonym
anonymity like that on like bumble and
tinder i don't like how hinges like
yeah calls you out literally for nerds
all right
yeah that's not for cool kids like sam
and i
we're still on tinder cruising with the
mills
uh but yeah every every app has a
different personality what what app do
you think on grindr how well do you do
on that i'm doing really good on that
i'm gay it's
because i'm a feminist and a little soft
little boy grinder is great weird though
i had a gay i was in the military i had
a friend that was i worked with it was
great
no
well that'd be an i heard about this
anyway it just surprises me how forward
like
they are on that app like yeah have you
ever shown this i've never been able hey
you want to go play cool and maybe [ __ ]
in the bathroom and i was like that was
the first message you got i was like
that's not what tinder is or
any of them at all it's not men and
women are different by sam kyper yeah uh
it just blows my mind it's like shocked
that grinder like men message men how
they message women on tinder yeah
imagine someone messaging the things you
message to women to you
uh and that's probably what's happening
yeah what's your opening line how do you
open what's your what's your opening
line
uh
um i don't know i usually try to find
something in the profile and talk about
it like
not only you meet someone organically in
the wild all right that's what i'm
better at anyway
no tone or personality to a message it
could come off creepy it also depends on
when they yeah [ __ ] unless you're
trying to get laid bro
all right say you meet someone
organically you're at like uh like a bar
you walk eyes across the room and like
time freezes all right she walks over to
you candace what do you say i said i
noticed i saw you staring at me game no
what's your boyfriend that's a crime i
need arrested i don't have a boyfriend
i'll be like hi i'm sam nice to meet you
if there's even a chance i don't like
that man back and he goes what's your
boyfriend's name i'm making up a name
so then i'll say uh
excuse me and then i'll walk past you
and i'll talk to
you go for the boyfriend question right
away that's that's kind of uh alabama it
kind of works actually it's like when
you're related they're locking eyes with
you already it's like
why are you staring at me you're trying
yeah it's really weird that you'd be
staring at it making me uncomfortable no
it doesn't make you i'm just saying like
it's your chances are good that they
don't have a boyfriend or
they're blind and
they don't have their glasses on do
blind spots has every blind person ever
stared at you is that yeah then you find
something
the madness the
so candace what do you think about sam
uh you think uh you could take him on a
date somewhere i think he could take me
on a date somewhere oh
such a feminist feminist pay for things
what uh what would you like to pay for
sam
i know we're right so
uh
plan b is cheaper i'll just say that uh
jesus christ
she's been on america ninja warrior
i mean
she's gonna find a plan b date
i mean the paddle board and like you
know everyone's with the paddleboard
whatever be original take her to a dog
park
he doesn't even own a dog
yeah we're just here watching for dog
that's what michael and hannah do you
think you want to go today to the dog
park she shows up and he has no dogs
in there i thought we could just watch
oh he's right there
would you go ahead from the corner
so uh yeah i mean you guys could go on a
date i think uh mini golf would be good
for you guys you would do it ironically
he would do it on face value
um
you know you could go to a bookstore you
could read to it
uh what illiterate king what's your
favorite book
do i look like i read
yeah kind of yeah you look like the only
person who read you read fantasy i think
like that's what i was saying
i read like
sometimes the best i got yeah to find
out if it's shampoo or not yeah
make it the smallest
word on there
uh sam uh what do you uh what are you
thinking about your chances you want to
maybe solidify it with the dance or like
absolutely
like we could salsa or something no all
right would you like this salsa for
sandwich
it's been your theme lately getting guys
up here to dance
well
you want to tell are you offering it are
you oh dance trying to
with royalty-free music it's not
new audience members
oh they're just sitting down
shifting around
look at that guy looks like [ __ ]
spider-man or a superman over there
very handsome man
candace what do you think about sam
after seeing this hunk of a man shifting
around this
oh my god he looks like he uh
he's about to uh challenge the ncaa
woman's swimming champion right now
anyways what uh what do you think about
austin men how long have you been in
austin six months six months so not that
much time
yeah they're uh they're terrifying
they're terrifying
but that's men everywhere right
okay
is there any particular uniqueness to
their terrifyingness
are they terrifying in a special way
maybe
i think there's something special in the
water in austin for sure
yeah that's what makes it so weird and
wacky man
they weren't lying when they said keep
austin weird the man took that to heart
yeah what's the weirdest thing a man's
man in austin has done
um i feel like every time quinn and i
are at buzzmill at least one of us has a
random drunk man grab our arm and
they're like i'm in love with you and
said please go away
that's actually sam's opening move
it's actually him boyfriend i'm in love
with
just like he grabbed my hand gingerly
and like twirled me around it was
beautiful
nice
next time you should grab his hand he
likes to be in the kitchen and cook and
clean apparently yeah compliments work
on me
tell me i did a good job cooking here
at toufee or i don't know i do feel like
like uh guys in austin like well it's
definitely one of those things
especially if they see a group of girls
they'll just say the weirdest [ __ ] ever
because i guess they think everyone's a
tourist it's so weird and especially
when we go places together um because we
both are always dressed in different
variations of looking just like this so
they see us together and it's like they
immediately like they'll go up to talk
to me and then candace will stare at
them and they'll leave me alone
like immediately she's a true feminist
he's got the uniform and everything it's
the bandana the tattoos yeah
so what's like some like they approach
candace like the more bookish like male
feminist like
weak types you know they're like well
actually i'm uh you know i'm actually
sensitive too
and then like the like the roided out
douche bags are like
quinn is like [ __ ] dope man
okay anyway
what kind of guy is it on you uh what
what are you guys doing you say notice
you notice the differences
between you two guys that hit on
what do you think sam would hit on
uh well sam what do you think about uh
going on a second date would you do it
and when
uh
yeah i mean why not let's go [ __ ] you
i feel like quinn made our date already
for us it's got to be paddle boarding or
something like that you're gonna be in
the background with a mustache and a
trench coat yeah i'm just like there
like in the backseat like where are we
going yeah
i feel like everyone like candace dates
looks like again like a variation of her
like the cody guy the first guy
i feel like her and him look like they'd
be on a date yeah
cody do you think that you guys would go
on a good date together
nice what would you do beekeeping
sounds beautiful we should trade him out
for sam or sam vice versa everyone's
saying
would you be willing to trade bandanas
with her
you could
your bandana has sentimental value
nice you wash it
is she dead is she still alive
okay then who gives a [ __ ]
it's a bad daddy
two bucks
hey ma look at him got laid and lost the
bandana she'll understand they'll look
at him
they look like they've been on a date
uh sam looks like he'd be on a date with
michael in a hand nice straight
seems like a good conversation
he actively constantly has his little
finger up in the back
anyways any last words you guys want to
say uh to each other
sounds like we're going on a date i feel
like that's nice yeah it's in the works
sam i hope you have a lot of money
because she's going to make you pay for
everything
can we get sponsored by the show maybe
could you guys pay for our date
abortions
sponsored by abortions
yeah we uh we need it you know it's
texas we don't know about condoms or
plan b or iuds
[Music]
but uh you guys look like you'd be very
responsible together you'd take care of
the kid and by taking care of it
murder
expeditiously
and not actually raising
uh give it up for candace and sam kiper
they went on a date together
we got time for one more we only have
two dudes in here we got candace in here
again
i put her back in the man's bucket any
uh any women want to go up on a date
tonight this is your chance
we need a woman
this guy's raising the hand of his
partner
if you want to come up here smith
she's coming up here and i know there's
a man
going to david
ministering woman number
superman's girlfriend let's go because
we get a text thing
they come
hopefully
i don't know your friends and my friends
together
that's so cool like we're
friends welcome
a very gentleman named victor paglia
going on a date with what's your name
megan and nick sapoglia give it up for
them one more time
go
hi megan nice to meet you
nicholas
it's nice to meet you nice to meet you
where are you from i'm from california
awesome yeah yeah which like what city
i'm from fresno okay why are you here um
i'm a comedian i've moved here to do
stand-up and
yeah
cool yeah i just came here to hang out
and get a drink i have a show across the
street at eight o'clock so let's just
come by to support the friends and
help make the show go better
welcome to texas thank you thank you
what's it like mike right by your mouth
what's it like going on a date in front
of your other date
funny yeah
clearly interesting
interesting how is he nice to you yeah
it's super nice super nice how many
dates have you gone on
probably a thousand because we've been
together for like
almost three years okay he wasn't
married no no and time give up for nick
sapoglia
yeah what's up hans
give it up for next apology and meg
megan meg
asking the tough questions
are you in a relationship currently i
like to get that out right away right
out of the way you know
it's a huge red flag you know yeah
nick you look like a pirate's son
what uh what have you been up to
recently in the dating world of austin i
haven't i haven't been doing any dating
at all really i've just been
working and
yeah stroking it yeah yeah you made
really helpful in all the maintenance
work
my god
uh doing uh doing comedy
meg megan
how did you meet your uh wonderful
boyfriend
the real story and the story they tell
each other
you meet at a better home and household
oh
yeah pardon nice oh i said uh did you
meet at a better home and household
photo shoot something like that yes
met at work you guys were both at work
kind of at work yes
well who approached who first
i think i think we should get him on
stage and just interview the both of
them well wouldn't you find that
convenient
you don't have to
show yourself to be a lesser man in
front of a
very very hot couple no why not
he's trying to be a third i don't know
if you guys are looking but
maybe that's why we're here
cameron oh he has a type
uh so would you uh would you want sam
kuiper to be watching or participating
in the bedroom
be a good director
yeah
i could i could get i could direct yeah
i could do that oh neck next to pogba
yeah you need uh someone to fix the
lighting fix the lighting you do that
you do that i love that yeah do a little
light flushing
yeah totally
there you go baby i'll keep it going
so what's the freakiest thing you guys
have done together have you guys had sex
in public yet
what was your favorite
place that you've had sex
your favorite public place you've got
stars
you mean you're letting all that wipe
out real jobs in a home
no
they can't get fired
in our backyard and like people could
see
yeah we've been watching
yeah you know those drones flying about
i make all my money right now
and uh he does like to uh you know near
the high uh
huh the hotel the window
okay some some creep with binoculars
that makes us sound like it was you nick
it might have been i mean i was just
that's
the mustache with a mustache like that
he's gotta watch you know what i mean
i've got binoculars you know
a man like that either like really
enjoys watching people have sex or he's
not allowed near public parks there's
not in between with a mustache like that
he gets instantly flagged at a
playground concealing
and parents get concerned
it's like watching a lion go to a
watering hole the parents are like oh
[ __ ]
uh nick what's the craziest thing you've
seen out in uh public
dating watch i see anyone [ __ ] public
like these two i saw some homeless
people doing it the other day oh were
they having fun hey i mean it looked
like it was like what position were they
in uh they're standing one or the other
yeah the homeless position where they're
facing a homeless position yeah that's
the only position they can do
they get some sixth grade on them
yeah that was probably the most action
i've seen in a couple months yeah yeah
nice
what do you think is wrong you think
you're not putting yourself out there
you're not making an effort yeah that
exactly yeah on purpose or like yeah i
mean i see you guys like every day where
i'm all i'm doing all i do is go out to
and do comedy and
he's grinding
he's on his grind oh my god yeah
what is your type what's like your dream
girl
nice yeah
i can see it's like i'm open to i'm open
to anything oh gosh typical guy yeah so
horny yeah mainly vagina yeah
i mean vagina yeah sometimes the mouth
is nice besides perfectly sculpted
beautiful men well who is your type
i like you know just
tall
dark
okay nick blue nick is getting fatter
and sad
he's neither 12.
yeah
just normal
average height white guy you know
normal average so what's the craziest
thing a date's done on a date before
like before you met what's his name uh
chris chris before chris
you know i really haven't gotten a ton
of dates in my life but the
weird guy in college uh
just picture nick
weird guy in college yeah in college
sounds like me
took me out to dinner and then we went
to a movie we saw
finding neverland i think was oh that's
a light-hearted snap as [ __ ] kids
dying oh what a [ __ ]
johnny depp
pre-amber heard
it was awful that sounds oh man
isn't it sweet aren't you like oh look
he has emotion no i was it like a
pathetic kind of crying like she was
just sad and unattractive i'm not gonna
lie i'm the type of girl that's like i
like sensitive men but if a man cries in
front of me like what you fruity or
something like what are you crying about
yeah crying movies i don't need you to
cry yes can't have two people crying
relationship who's gonna dab whose eyes
it's gonna look ridiculous exactly it's
true
so um have you all been dating
uh almost three years wow three years
almost a thousand dates together
please so it's like a
covid couple
yeah we met right before coven so we had
a few months together and then covet
happen and did you all move in together
since like you had to be in a pod
totally moved in together yeah how soon
oh god like technically like three
months in but our situation is very
weird like we got we have kids we were
going through divorces the whole thing
oh you're both divorced
and alcoholics yes that's great for a
sitcom i'm not gonna lie
so you guys both drank a lot during the
pandemic one of the few couples that
made it yeah congratulations
he says uh it's shaky but
what's uh what's your favorite thing to
do together
other than drink other than
drink copious amounts of alcohol exactly
uh
travel everywhere
okay some big things about white if you
know what i mean yeah i'm not gonna
y'all are both so very attractive that
it looks like y'all either like have sex
in missionary or you're into only like
freaky weird [ __ ] and there's not in
between the second she said legally
going to hotel rooms in costa rica
so you're more 50 shades of grey
i think we both are nice
good for you chris you got to keep it
crazy you know nick is down for anything
so i can't wait to get divorced nick
would you ever be tight everyone should
nick would you ever be tied up or are
you always a tire upper
i've done both
what have they done to you when you're
tied up take advantage of you in any way
i kidnapped you
yeah that's when i was four no i'm just
kidding um
yeah just i don't know she just tied me
up and had had her away with me had sex
with me it was great
boring
i mean
i was tied up i couldn't do anything
except take it yeah
women make the worst sadistic
[ __ ]
what's that supposed to mean it's like
uh you guys don't commit war crimes as
much as as men do
yeah in bed uh yeah
yeah fair enough still got it man
on that one rapist
um meg what's the uh
what's uh what's something that you
would like to do
on or near nick
on let's go let's do on bareback him or
no i can't say that in front of your
boyfriend
i don't know english saddle or
i don't even know what an english saddle
is
i'm not sure what that is what the [ __ ]
is the amazon position it's just like
two-day free shipping
amazon prime
jeff bezos just shows up
her amazon position is jeff bezos she
just watches you
creepily i pay for this
uh yeah uh what do you guys think you
guys think you go on a date again yeah
totally
do this yeah what would you do
paddleboard no
um what could we do we could throw darts
yeah i'll continue okay
sure yeah and chris will uh he'll
videotape yeah you can get the darts a
little bit i've always wanted to like
have a first date or like a date like
just recorded the whole time yeah that'd
be amazing just have a nice moment like
memento from it
you can watch it later and you can
critique yourself yeah
sure what's your astrological signs
aquarius i'm a taurus
what are your signs
aquarius leo
i'm a leo yeah
oh he's just steeler just like out of
nowhere come in it's the same thing
right the both leos same thing yeah
a little little lion over there
splashing around in the water that he is
um
nick what's the craziest astrological
sign you've been mashed up with
austrologist
astrological
i don't know virgos and cancers were
pretty fun but also pretty crazy i guess
in my experience whereas in cancers
yeah i don't know
what's the worst date you've been on
i was on a date one time and i thought
it was like going pretty well just
normal date nothing too special but
um
my date got up and went to the bathroom
yeah and some guy approached me and it
was uh his brother's girlfriend so he
was like uh damn you just finding
yourself in this situation
why do you think i asked right away
fair enough like so that was like oh
really and i was like i saw she was in
the bathroom and he's like for real and
he like showed me like family pictures
like and stuff like like them at like
their family function and her and i'm
always like all right cool i just like
left damn that's like really awkward
yeah no one mines their birds
why don't you say your last name
sapaglia
how do you think you say it
he's he says sapoglia but i'll give it
to you no i think i'm saying wrong too
yeah most people are yes the wonderful
dater
the story about how he
dated someone incorrectly or something
give it up for him and meg they went on
a date together thanks thanks for having
us thank you for coming on that was uh
that was the show
uh this is quinn
follow her on instagram um anything you
want to plug
um i have if you all like watching uh
stuff about relationships i have a
podcast with my friend megan called the
excommunication podcast
where we have like people come on and
talk about their shitty relationships
and then we talk about stuff too so
check it out it's like a more competent
version of this show
someone who actually dates people giving
out dating advice
uh but this has been the show give it up
for everyone who came out and jimmy and
sam and have a good night thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you